NIGHT IN NEW YORK.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON.
A LOT GOING ON TONIGHT.
IT’S BEEN UNBELIEVABLE 24
HOURS, NEWS CHRISTMAS.
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN THIS
EVENING WITH THE MOST
PREDICTABLE THING THAT’S
HAPPENED.
HEADLINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACQUITTED BY
U.S. SENATE.
JUST HAPPENED.
IMPEACHMENT IS FINALLY OVER.
THE RESULT WAS NEVER IN
DOUBT.
THE WHOLE THING WAS LIKE
WATCHING TITANIC, REALLY.
>> ICEBERG AHEAD.
[CRASHING]
>> Tucker: PRETTY GRIPPING,
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE OPENING SCENES YOU KNOW
THE BOAT IS GOING TO SINK IN
THE END.
SAME IN WASHINGTON.
NO MATTER HOW FERVENTLY
DEMOCRATS WISHED OTHERWISE,
THE PRESIDENT WAS ALWAYS
GOING TO REMAIN IN OFFICE.
AND AS PREDICTED, BOTH
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES FAILED
IN THE SENATE TODAY.
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS WENT
DOWN 53-47.
THE ABUSE OF POWER CHARGE
FAILED 52 TO 48.
A LONE REPUBLICAN, AS YOU
MAY HAVE READ, DEFECTED AND
JOINED THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT DEFENDANT SHALL GO
UNNAMED ON THIS SHOW ON THE
GROUNDS THAT SILLY MORAL
PREENING SHOULD NOT BE
PUBLICITY IT IS DESIGNED TO
GARNER.
OVERLECTURE FROM A PRIVATE
EQUITY GUY?
NEXT THING YOU KNOW SOME
PAYDAY LOAN SLEAZE BALL WILL
BE TELLING US HE A WOULD ALL
GOING TO HELL.
IT’S TOO ABSURD EACH FOR THE
LUDICROUS MOMENT WE ARE
LIVING.
IN WE WILL TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY AS WE DECIDE AL
SHARPTON IS A LEGITIMATE
MORAL VOICE.
BACK REALITY THOUGH NOW THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS OVER MAYBE WE
CAN HAVE OUR COUNTRY BACK.
FROM LAST SEPTEMBER UNTIL
TODAY, UKRAINE WAS THE ONLY
THING THAT MATTERED IN
WASHINGTON.
THAT’S AN AWFUL LOT OF
WASTED TIME.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, IT’S MORE
TIME THAT AMERICA SPENT
DECLARING, FIGHTING AND
WINNING THE SPANISH AMERICAN
WAR.
WHAT DO WE GET FOR IT IN THE
END?
NOTHING, REALLY.
NO TANGIBLE BENEFITS AT ALL.
WE DID LEARN QUITE A BIT
ABOUT.
SO CHARACTERS INVOLVED IN
THE FARCE.
WE FOUND OUT THAT ADAM
SCHIFF IS A BUDDING
THESPIAN.
WHO KNEW?
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT NANCY
PELOSI ISN’T SIMPLY THE
LEADER OF A POLITICAL PARTY.
SHE IS ALSO A WOMAN OF
PROFOUND FAITH AS WELL AS
BOTTOMLESS SADNESS.
HER DAYS ARE CONSUMED BY
PRAYING AND WEEPING.
>> THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I SAY THIS TO YOU WITH GREAT
SORROW AND PRAYERFULLY.
>> FIRST, LET ME SAY THAT
THIS IS NO CAUSE FOR ANY
JOY.
THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
IT’S REALLY SAD.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY
PRAYERFUL.
I PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT ALL
THE TIME.
>> THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS NO JOY IN THIS.
IT’S SAD.
>> Tucker: WOW.
NOT A BREEZY PERSON THAT
NANCY PELOSI.
THANKFULLY, NOW THAT
IMPEACHMENT HAS ENDED,
PELOSI CAN RESUME HER LIGHT
OF SPIRITUAL CONTEMPLATION.
WE WILL BE RETURNING TO HER
VETS INDUSTRY DUTIES AT THE
CHURCH OF THIRD TRIMESTER
ABORTION ON MARKET STREET
AND WE WISH HER WELL.
IF THERE IS ANY GOOD NEWS TO
COME FROM IMPEACHMENT WE NOW
KNOW WHAT REALLY MATTERS TO
OUR LEADERS IN WASHINGTON.
IF YOU GUESSED YOUR SAFETY,
HAPPINESS AND WELL-BEING WE
WILL HAVE TO PAUSE HERE TO
GIGGLE BITTERLY.
IT’S DEFINITELY NOT THAT.
SORRY.
WHAT REALLY MATTERS TO THEM
AND YOU HAVE LEARNED THIS IS
THE NATION OF UKRAINE, WHICH
IS SOMEWHERE NEAR RUSSIA, AS
WE HAVE OFTEN BEEN TOLD
THESE PAST FIVE MONTHS, IT
IS OUR HIGHEST AND MOST
SACRED DUTY TO SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THAT
INCLUDES GIVING THEM
SOPHISTICATED WEAPON SYSTEMS
WHENEVER THEY ASK FOR THEM
AND NEVER EVER DELAYING THE
DELIVERY OF THOSE WEAPONS
EVEN FOR A MOMENT.
LISTEN TO HONORARY UKRAINIAN
ADAM SCHIFF EXPLAIN.
>> THE WIDELY ACCEPTED FACT
OF UKRAINE’S IMPORTANCE TO
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY MAKES
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ABUSE OF
POWER WITHHOLDING OF VITAL
DIPLOMATIC AND MILITARY
SUPPORT ALL THE MORE
DISTURBING.
WE ONLY DETER RUSSIA BY
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATING
SUPPORT FOR OUR FRIENDS,
FRIENDS LIKE UKRAINE.
THAT IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR SECURITY
THAT WE STAND WITH UKRAINE.
COUNTRIES LIKE UKRAINE, ARE
FIGHTING OUR FIGHT AGAINST
AUTHORITARIANISM.
GOD HELP US IF IT’S NOT OUR
FIGHT, STILL.
>> Tucker: GOD HELP US IF WE
EVER ABANDON UKRAINE.
HILARIOUS.
IMAGINE IF DEMOCRATS HAD
GONE IN ANOTHER MORE
CONVENTIONAL DIRECTION LIKE
DROP UKRAINE TALK AND
INSTEAD SPENT THE LAST FIVE
MONTHS WORKING ON, I DON’T
KNOW, THE STUDENT LOAN
DISASTER OR LOWERING
INSURANCE PREMIUMS OR
HELPING YOUNG PEOPLE BUILD
FUNCTIONING FAMILIES?
THEY COULD HAVE DONE THAT,
BUT THEY DIDN’T.
THEY IGNORED IT.
INSTEAD THEY JAMMERRED ON
FOR MONTHS ABOUT SOME
MEANINGLESS PHONE CALL WITH
A UKRAINIAN.
NOBODY OUTSIDE TWITTER EVER
CARED.
NOT FOR ONE MINUTE.
THE COUNTRY WAS ALWAYS BORED
BY.
THIS AFTER A FEW MONTHS,
VOTERS BECAME ANNOYED AND
THEN THEY BECAME DISGUSTED
AND THE FINAL RESULT WAS AS
PREDICTABLE AS TODAY’S VOTE
WAS NEW GALLUP POLL SHOWS
THE PRESIDENT WITH THE
HIGHEST APPROVAL RATING OF
HIS PRESIDENCY.
HIGHER THAN THE DAY HE WAS
INAUGURATED.
WHO DID THAT?
DEMOCRATS DID THAT.
IMPEACHMENT DIDN’T JUST
FAIL, IT HELPED THE MAN THEY
SAY THEY HATE.
BUT YOU SHOULDN’T BE
SURPRISED.
OF COURSE IT DID.
LIKE TITANIC, THE ENDING WAS
OBVIOUS FROM THE OPENING